wir machen hier direkt weiter wie
angekündigt mit dem Herausgeber Carsten
Knop dem hessischen Ministerpräsidenten
Boris rein und Matthias Maurer einem
Astronauten und es geht um die Frage wie
wir noch Großes erreichen viel Spaß und
herzlich willkommen auf dem Podium Herr
Ministerpräsident
hallo sorry
[Applaus]
ja hallo herzlich willkommen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ich nutze
diese verteilzeit gerade noch mal kurz
um noch mal ordentlich Hallo zu sagen
bitte auch ein Verzeihung dass ich das
jetzt so nahtlos anschließen muss
aber wir müssen natürlich und das ist
letztlich auch in Ihrem Interesse die
Zeit die uns bei der Eingangskontrolle
verloren gegangen ist wieder ein wenig
reinholen ähm es ist wirklich toll zu
sehen wie viele von ihnen hier sind und
wie viele von ihnen sich für die FAZ das
was wir tun und unsere Gesprächspartner
interessieren danke dafür so und jetzt
wird's im Saal auch so langsam wieder
ruhiger und ähm ich begrüße auch noch
mal ähm von meiner Seite sehr herzlich
den Ministerpräsidenten des Landes
Hessen Boris rein guten Morgen kommen
und Matthias malaura ESA Astronaut und
du lieber Matthias haben wir uns in
Davos kennengelernt und auch sofort
irgendwie sehr sehr gut verstanden war
es heute vor zwölf Monaten noch in der
ISS im All und und hast Hessen umkreist
und
sie lieber Herr Ministerpräsident waren
vor einem Jahr noch gar nicht
Ministerpräsident sondern
Landtagspräsident und in ihren früheren
Rollen
Wissenschaftsminister und unter anderem
natürlich auch für diese Universität mit
zuständig und und Innenminister und
Staatssekretär im Innenministerium und
sind schon sehr sehr lange in der
hessischen Politik unterwegs und genau
sie sind dann im Mai vergangenen
jahresministerpräsident geworden und du
lieber Matthias bisschen Mai vergangenen
Jahres von der ISS gesund und munter
zurückgekehrt und das ist ja auch keine
Kleinigkeit und so fern hat er meint es
vergangenen Jahres für euch beide für
sie beide ja einiges an Veränderung
gebracht es ist aber nicht der einzige
Grund
warum jetzt hier ein ESA Astronaut und
ein Ministerpräsident auf der Bühne
sitzen sondern wir haben ja auch ein ein
Thema für diesen
Kongress nämlich es geht um Fortschritt
es geht darum
wie man Deutschland voranbringen kann
wie man den Klimawandel begegnen kann
wie man überhaupt irgendwie wieder etwas
schneller etwas bewegt vielleicht auch
Großes erreichen kann
etwas wo man das Gefühl hat dass das in
der Politik eigentlich kaum noch
funktioniert war kaum ist irgendetwas
beschlossen melden sich ganz viele
Interessengruppen zerredendes und
irgendwann kommen dann noch
Kleinigkeiten dabei raus und dabei haben
wir doch alle das Gefühl und es jetzt
auch schon in verschiedenen Panels heute
gehört es muss unbedingt mal wieder was
Großes passieren und im All passieren
große Dinge da hat man zwischendurch das
nicht nur das Gefühl sondern es war eine
Tatsache es ist passiert wenig es ist
wurde so ausgeatmet und und jetzt ist
der Mond vor uns und der Mars sogar und
man hat alle möglichen Dinge im erdnern
Orbit vor und Weltraum es wird sich
wieder richtig spannend geworden und
möglicherweise kann die Politik daraus
ja ein bisschen was lernen und du lieber
Matthias das da oben auch im All Dinge
gesehen und erforscht eigentlich hat er
da oben nämlich nur Beton gemischt wird
Zitat auf der Erde auch helfen können so
übrigens habe ich gegenüber meinen
beiden Diskussionsteilnehmern einen
Vorteil ich war schon auf der Welt als
wir zum ersten Mal auf dem Mond gelandet
sind Jahrgang 1970 in der 1972 hat es
nicht geschafft ja so ja
müssen
alle von der Apollo Generation genau so
also
lieber Herr Ministerpräsident täuscht
der Eindruck dass die gesellschaftliche
Debatte sich zunehmen darum dreht das
Dinge verboten werden sollten und immer
weniger die Möglichkeiten von
Innovationen und Wachstum gesehen werden
naja sie es wird schon oft oder schon
lange darüber diskutiert dass zu Verbot
zu viel Verbote ausgesprochen werden das
ist zu viel bewegt zu wenig Bewegung
gibt dass ich sag mal auch zu wenig
Freiräume geschaffen werden aber ich
muss Ihnen sagen
wenn ich das mal obwohl ich hier bei der
FAZ bin so flapsig ausdrücken darf mir
geht es zunehmend auf die Nerven
dass mehr und mehr Verbote in der Tat
ausgesprochen werden das geht bei den
Heizungen los das geht über den
Verbrenner bis hin zum Bau von
Einfamilienhäusern und so weiter und so
fort also ich muss ihn ganz ehrlich
sagen es ist mehr und mehr so ein Stream
da wo es nicht mehr darum geht dass man
eigenverantwortlich Dinge macht sondern
dass der Staat einfach entscheidet wie
etwas zu sein hat ohne dass es auch
ausdiskutiert wird und wenn ich über die
Themen die über die ich eben gesprochen
habe wir wissen natürlich warum und was
der Hintergrund für diese Diskussionen
ist der Hintergrund ist natürlich dass
wir uns bereit machen wollen für CO2
Neutralität dass wir uns bereit machen
wollen für die dekarbonisierung auch für
die Transformation keine Frage aber was
mir mehr und mehr und ich habe das eben
so flapsig gesagt was mir mehr und mehr
Unbehagen bereitet ist dass damit
natürlich auch ja in einem ziemlichen
großen Umfang ja der Fortschrittsglaube
eigentlich vollkommen flöten geht das
nicht dass das nicht mehr Dinge weiter
erforscht werden sondern dass man
einfach sagt verbieten und deswegen sage
ich ähm es ist besser etwas zu
verbessern als es zu verbieten und das
ist eben im großen Ganzen auch immer
unsere Stärke gewesen Dinge einfach
weiter zu entwickeln und nehmen Sie mal
den verbrenner motor wie es hier nicht
populistisch sein aber wir haben also
recht populistisch ja aber wir haben
eine wir haben eine
125-jährige ein 525-jährigen Vorsprung
in der Entwicklung dieser Antriebsart
die holt niemand mehr auf die holt auch
China nicht nicht mehr auf und das
wissen die Chinesen auch und
die Chinesen haben deswegen ja nicht aus
umweltpolitischen Gründen gesagt wir
entwickeln einen anderen Antrieb nämlich
die Batterie oder die Batterie Antrieb
sondern sie haben es gesagt aus
wettbewerbspolitischen gründen und exakt
diese Moment
räumt im Grunde genommen die Europäische
Union diese Technologie einfach
sozusagen zurück das gleiche erleben wir
an anderen Stellen gerade jetzt im
Rahmen dieser Energiekrise dass wir
etwas abschalten ohne eine ein Übergang
zu haben also sie würden ja wenn sie
nehmen sie mal ihre Kühltruhe die hat
möglicherweise ein rotes ehe das freut
einen nicht sie brauchen jetzt eine
Kühltruhe mit dem grünen arm aber sie
würden in der Zwischenzeit nicht einfach
die ganzen Steaks und alles was sie da
eingefroren haben rausräumen und die
irgendwie auftauen lassen und warten bis
sie dann die neue Kühltruhe haben
sondern sie würden das erst dann machen
wenn Sie die neue Technologie haben oder
sie würden sogar hingehen vielleicht
könnten sie das ja und würden diese
Kühltruhe mit dem roten e
weiterentwickeln dass sie
klimafreundlicher wird und das fehlt mir
derzeit in der Diskussion der
politischen Diskussion ich weiß
natürlich dass das damit zu tun hat dass
die Geschwindigkeiten immer größer
werden das natürlich auch die Sorge
immer größer wird wir haben jetzt vier
Jahre als Regierung wir müssen jetzt all
das umsetzen was wir da umsetzen wollen
aber ich glaube dass in einer solchen
Situation eben nicht nur Sorgfalt
vorschnelligkeit geht ähm sondern auch
Verantwortung vor Schnelligkeit geht und
insbesondere wir mehr darauf setzen
sollten wirklich eine
technologieoffenheit wieder zu
entwickeln 360 Grad jetzt ist nicht die
Zeit für Ideologen jetzt ist die Zeit
für Ingenieure und deswegen würde ich
mir sehr wünschen dass wir viel
Geschwindigkeit aus dem ein oder anderen
rausnehmen würden denn ich kann das
verstehen wenn man das unter normalen
Umständen alles so machen würde aber
jetzt haben wir ja eine Situation wo man
nicht einfach etwas stur abarbeiten kann
sondern wir haben jetzt vor der Haustür
einen Krieg wir haben eine ganz
schwierige Energie Situation und
deswegen müssen wir im Grunde genommen
auf all das jetzt setzen was wir haben
aber nicht vergessen eben das was wir
haben weiterhin das wäre mein Plädoyer
weniger verbieten und mehr verbessern
jetzt geht's ja dieser Fridays for
future Bewegung und auch wir sind hier
heute alle etwas intensiver durchsucht
worden weil ein Lippenstift ja auch
eventuell ein Klebestift hätte gewesen
sein können
und die jungen Leute sind ja auch also
sie sind ja engagierte junge Leute das
ist ja ohne jeden Zweifel so und und sie
sehen sich ja eigentlich Verbote herbei
warum sollten gerade junge Menschen
davor besonders skeptisch sein wenn
pauschal Verbote gefordert wird ich
glaube dass
die Gefahr ist wenn man
pauschalverbote ausspricht die Gefahr
besteht darin dass junge Leute keine
Erfahrungen mehr machen können und dass
sie eben nicht die Chance haben und auch
nicht die Gelegenheit bekommen von ihrem
Staat von ihren Eltern von denjenigen
die im Grunde genommen Augenblick hier
die Geschäfte zu führen haben
mündig zu werden mündig kann man nämlich
erst dadurch werden dass man wirklich in
fahr entsprechende Erfahrungen macht und
dieser Erfahrungen werden Menschen
beraubt wenn Verbote von vornherein
ausgesprochen werden das doch auch der
Grund warum man in Diktaturen genau mit
dem instrum jedes Verbot des arbeitet
weil man eben nicht möchte dass Menschen
mündig sind dass man nicht möchte dass
Menschen eigene Meinung entwickeln weil
man nicht möchte dass Menschen eigene
Wege entwickeln und genau das nehmen
sich junge Leute oder das wird junge
Leute genommen diese diese
Erfahrungshorizonte und damit natürlich
auch diese lernmomente wenn es aus wenn
wir ausschließlich versuchen zu regieren
und zu administrieren über Verbote und
ich glaube das gerade junge Menschen
Lust darauf haben Erfahrungen zu machen
das gerade junge Menschen darauf Lust
haben auch mal zu erfahren geht das so
oder geht das so und was passiert wenn
ich falsch mache um eben daraus seine
Lehre zu ziehen und das wird jungen
Menschen genommen deswegen finde ich es
manchmal ein bisschen traurig wie die
Debatte derzeit läuft aber wissen Sie
was ich war nämlich ist dass die Leute
das ist nicht nur mir so geht dass ich
die Nase voll davon habe dass mehr und
mehr ich in die Diskussionen erlebe dass
Leute sagen es ist mal gut jetzt wollen
wir es mal wieder ein bisschen anders
haben das haben was das haben wir es
erstmal so versucht das wird nicht zum
Ziel ähm wir wollen frei sein wir wollen
Erfahrungen machen wir wollen im Übrigen
nicht passiv sein denn es verboten ist
ja was furchtbar passives sondern wir
wollen aktiv sein wir wollen Aktivität
entwickeln und wir wollen weiter Dinge
entwickeln und uns nicht quasi sagen
lassen was richtig und was falsch ist
das können wir als mündige Bürger schon
selbst herausfinden
Matthias wenn ihr da oben im Weltall in
diesen unendlichen weih hat unendlichen
Weiten unterwegs seid wo die Freiheit
vielleicht noch grenzenloser ist als
über den Wolken seid ihr inzwischen bei
der ESA aber natürlich auch bei der NASA
eigentlich wie Volkshochschule Lehrer
unterwegs und erklärt tatsächlich also
im Sinne von wir machen euch mündig auch
Fortschritt Wissenschaft warum das
notwendig ist es ist ein Teil der
Motivation dessen die dich angetrieben
hat Astronaut zu werden auch in diese
Rolle hinein zu schlüpfen ja das
Astronaut ist man eigentlich vieles in
einer Person also dort oben sind wir
Wissenschaftler Forscher ich bin auch
Ingenieur ich mag die tolle Technologie
und dann das Teamwork internationale
Teams das finde ich sehr bereichernd
auch über ja über den eigenen Horizont
hinauszuschauen nicht nur die deutsche
Brille aufzuhaben sondern mit anderen
Menschen die jeden anderen aktuellen
Hintergrund haben andere Sprachen haben
gemeinsam eine große Herausforderung
anzugehen das waren so für mich die
Beweggründe Astronaut zu werden und
natürlich erst Abenteuer dass ich danach
auch Botschafter werde und eigentlich
ich denke mal zehnmal mehr Zeit
ja vor der Kamera stehe oder eine
Öffentlichkeit stehe als ich im
Endeffekt als Astronaut im alle arbeite
das war mir anfangs nicht so bewusst
aber das ist ganz ganz wichtig weil als
Astronaut hat man auch eine
vorbild-rolle und ähm ich hätte
präsentiere sozusagen dass man einen
Traum auch einen großen Traum dass der
erfüllt werden kann und der nur jemand
der im großen Traum hat der der kann
dieses Ziel auch hatte reichen und das
ist die Hauptbotschaft die ich an die
Jugend immer weitergeben möchte lasst
euch von niemanden sagen ihr könnt das
nicht oder ihr seid zu klein dafür in
jedem da draußen steckt ein Astronaut
also laut sein ist eigentlich super
einfach es ist halt nur es gibt zu wenig
Möglichkeiten hoch zu fliegen das ist
der Engpass und deswegen ist die Auswahl
ein bisschen strenger aber wirklich es
ist es ist nicht so schwer und die die
Erfahrung die man sammelt wenn man erst
einmal gesehen hat ich kann eigentlich
deutlich mehr erreichen als ich mir
vielleicht als Kind oder als junger
Erwachsener zugetraut habe das ist etwas
ganz ganz tolles und das geht natürlich
sehr viel positive Energie und diese
Energie möchte ich weitergeben ich
möchte Jugend dann auch inspirieren und
sagen macht was nehmt die Sachen aktiv
in die Hand ich habe neulich hatte ich
einen Gast in der Redaktion
die hat mir gesagt wenn man Kinder
derzeit Bilder malen lässt malen die
viel häufiger so düsterere Szenarien
Dystopien von denen sie Angst haben und
es ist nicht mehr das wie bei uns früher
sommer Sonne Sonnenschein und so ähm das
heißt dann das was du machst wäre an der
Stelle dann ja besonders wichtig
den den jungen Leuten wenn man so will
die Angst zu klemmen und ihnen zu sagen
nein also ihr müsst jetzt nicht von
Vater Staat umarmt werden sondern um
auch das noch mal aufzugreifen ist im
Ministerpräsident gesagt hat sondern
nehmt euch das was ihr könnt und macht
es einfach ganz genau also ich sehe
meine Rolle zunehmend auch darin zu
erklären eine Utopie ist möglich und
wenn man sich die Nachrichten anschaut
dann hört man nur Krieg
Klimakatastrophe ist irgendwie alles
schwarz und und
es ist klar für mich dass die Jugend
heute keine Lust auf die Zukunft hat
also mir fehlt da die Euphorie dass man
sagt okay es gibt die Herausforderung
aber die können wir angehen die müssen
wir angehen aber es gibt definitiv eine
ganz ganz tolle Zukunft und ihr müsst
euch nehmen ihr müsst sie gestalten
jetzt hast du
jetzt warst du im All in einem ganz
besonderen Moment du warst ja auf der
Internationalen Raumstation am 24
Februar des vergangenen Jahres und du
warst da mit Kollegen zusammen und
Kollegen aus Russland und Kollegen aus
der Ukraine genau wie war das ja also
als Astronaut Internationale Raumstation
vor Jahren hat die international
Raumstation den Preis gewonnen
westfälischer Friedenspreis also Ende
des 30-jährigen Krieges ganz einfach
weil wir dort oben seit März zwei
Jahrzehnten zeigen durch internationale
Kooperation können wir Dinge bewegen die
kein einziges Land alleine gestalten
kann und dadurch tragen wir seit langem
zur Stabilität in Europa in der Welt bei
die Internationale Raumstation ist ja
eigentlich eine Station aus zwei
Stationen und am Ende des Kalten Krieges
wurde die amerikanische Station Alpha
mit der nachfolgestation mir also
nachdem mir dann sozusagen
zusammengestöp und fliegt jetzt als
einzige Station dort oben rum das sehen
wir jeden Tag also der russischen Seite
gibt es eine andere Spannungsversorgung
die Kühlsysteme funktionieren anders die
Türen haben einen anderen Durchmesser
wie in der Schweiz das ist das ist
wirklich sind zwei Raumstationen die
zusammengestöpselt wurden aber sichtbar
und gewollt und kein Teil der Station
kann alleine fliegen wir sind
gegenseitig aufeinander angewiesen in
abhängig voneinander und das klappt und
für uns war es klar wir sind ein Vorbild
für die Erde und die Erde aus unserer
Perspektive ist nichts anderes als ein
großes Raumschiff also Planet Erde
Raumschiff Erde halten ein paar mehr
Astronauten auf diesem Raumschiff als
auf dem kleinen dort oben aber für uns
ist es klar eine Raumschiff kann nur
funktionieren wenn die Besatzung an
einem Strang zieht wenn wir vertrauen
haben wenn wir alle das gleiche Ziel
verfolgen und dass wir von oben runter
schauen und sehen plötzlich auf diesem
großen Raumschiff Erde fangen die Leute
an und und beschießen sich töten sich
dass etwas Unvorstellbares also für mich
ist dort oben sprichwörtlich eine Welt
zusammengebrochen und am 24 Februar was
so wir hatten das ja dann wir haben
Internet oben sind dann auch mit
Nachrichten verbunden also ich kann dort
auch Podcast hören oder Nachrichten
sehen
haben wir das verfolgt und es war für
uns unvorstellbar dass es wirklich zum
Musik kommt ich denke wie viele Menschen
die auf dem auf der Erde auch und als
wir dann am 24 über die Ukraine geflogen
sind und die Tage danach da hat es sich
sichtbar etwas verändert die Erde ist
nachts dort wo die Städte sind schön
beleuchtet also wenn man über Europa
kommt dann sieht man Paris London wenn
der looks gibt's tolle ganz ganz helle
Städte Deutschland ist mir so ein
bisschen gleich verteilt und sieht
wunderschön aus der italienische Stiefel
und dann kommt man über die Kleine auch
ganz toll beleuchtet bis auf diesen 24
februar und die Tage danach da war das
Land plötzlich schwarz da war ein Loch
in Europa wir schauen uns was ist mit
der Ukraine passiert
dort ging sprichwörtlich das Licht aus
klar die Leute haben Verdunkelung
gemacht weil sie angegriffen wurden
damit sie nicht bombardiert werden
konnten und der Krieg war mit eigenen
Augen sichtbar und und das waren ganz
bitterer Moment dort oben wir haben das
auch angesprochen mit den russischen
Kollegen und da war klar für die
russischen Kollegen war der Krieg
genauso wie für uns also die
schlechteste aller Lösungen oder es ist
gar keine Lösung muss man sagen
wir haben das besprochen und besonders
für einen meiner russischen Kollegen was
besonders bitter ist nämlich Familie in
Russland aber auch Familie und der
Ukraine und das kommt ja sehr sehr oft
vor dass die Familien auf zwei Seiten
sitzen und ähm ja dass man bitte den
Moment
an einem Strang ziehen gemeinsam Großes
erreichen miteinander in
großes Ziel verfolgen versus Koalition
Diskurs mit der Gesellschaft mit
Interessengruppen in der Gesellschaft
in der mittenden Ministerpräsident oder
auch ein Bundeskanzler den sehen wir
heute auch noch der das irgendwie
moderieren und nach vorne bringen muss
und in diesem kleinen
geht alles kaputt und die Gesellschaft
hat man das Gefühl zieht schon lange
nicht mehr in irgendeiner Hinsicht an
einem Strang sie zerfällt in
Partikularinteressen und es ist das
Gegenteil von dem was Matthias im
Weltall erlebt hat womit die jetzt die
Erde umkreisen und Bart auf dem Mond
sein werden und den Maß anstreben da
läuft was falsch oder das nächste Mal
bin ich das ist richtig wohltuend wir
Maurer sagte Leute ähm jetzt hört mal
auf mit diesen mit diesen die tropischen
Gedanken und mit diesen
es geht alles unter und es ist alles
vorbei sondern ein Forscher ein
Wissenschaftler der auch mal den
Gesamtüberblick hatte weil ich so sagen
darf sagt leute es geht voran es geht
immer weiter wenn ihr wollt dass es
weitergeht und es geht nicht unter uns
am Ende irgendwann und wir haben ja
mittlerweile so echt so eine dystopische
Stimmung wurde das Gefühl hast wenn du
das nicht machst bis dahin und wenn du
die Frist nicht erfüllt und dann das
nicht abgeschaltet hast dann geht es
aber hier richtig den Bach runter so und
das ist hat mit der mit der Realität
wenig zu tun deswegen bin ich unendlich
dankbar dass auch Leute gibt die so
sprechen wie sie und auch erstmal
einfach nach vorne gehen und sagen so
und so ist das also es ist schon mal für
mich sehr wohltuende weil ich Diskussion
oftmals anders erlebe aber das was sie
gefragt haben mehr Knoop ähm ist ganz
interessant ich glaube dass insgesamt
auch in der Politik auch um im Umgang
der Politik miteinander die Lage
eigentlich besser ist als sie derzeit
aussieht haha ja ja also ich muss ein
bisschen aufpassen dass gegen meine
eigenen Interessen Rede aber nein ich
will da ich will da ich versuche das
wirklich ganz ganz differenziert
darzustellen also natürlich haben wir
eine Koalition auf Bundesebene die gar
nichts voranbringt Ciao
okay das war der das war der eine Teil
den muss ich jetzt sagen ja genau also
das ist wirklich das ja das ist ja ein
Zyklus denn die haben also erst wird
groß was angekündigt also aber riesig
als wieder da verändert riesige
Veränderung ähm dann wird wahnsinnig
gezockt dann wird nur gestritten und
dann gibt's Stillstand das ist ein
Zyklus die nämlich mittlerweile war
zaubern zögern zoffen das ist natürlich
schwierig und es funktioniert auch nicht
einerseits andererseits oder muss ich
auch zu Ehrenrettung der Bundesregierung
und zu dem Gesamtkonzept sagen weil ähm
dieses Land ist ja ein föderales Land
und das Land wird hier nicht nur vom
Bund regiert sondern eben auch von 16
Bundesländern und das ist gut so sage
ich Ihnen auch wenn der ein oder andere
sagt mensch das ist ein Flickenteppich
und ihr macht er in den Ländern was ihr
wollt nein das ist ein ziemlich sich gut
ergänzendes und auch funktionierendes
System wir kommen auf
Ministerpräsidenten Konferenzen zusammen
die Regierungschefs der Länder mit dem
Bundeskanzler und finden einen Weg und
wir haben zwei riesige Krisen gemeistert
und wir sind in einer noch mittendrin
wer hätte gedacht dass wir so aus Corona
rauskommen wer hätte auch gedacht dass
wir wirtschaftlich so aus Corona
rauskommen als das alles losging die
Leute sieht man wir haben uns ja nicht
vorstellen können ich glaube sie haben
vorher mit kurz darüber gesprochen wir
haben uns ja nicht vorstellen können
dass es mal ausgangsverbote gibt ich
hätte das nicht für rechtlich
durchsetzbar gehalten und jetzt auch gar
nicht gewollt aber das ist eine andere
Themen und da gibt's ja noch viele
andere Beispiel das wäre dass wir dass
wir unternehmen gesagt haben oder auch
Leben gesagt haben du musst dann
schließen darfst nicht aufmachen du
darfst nicht wirtschaften und trotzdem
sind wir wieder rausgekommen weil wir es
hinbekommen haben auch mit Geld
beispielsweise in Hesse haben wir in
Hessen haben wir die hessischen
Unternehmen mit rund 18 Milliarden Euro
unterstützt daraus zu kommen am Ende hat
sie es gelohnt weil wir haben ja
Steuerzahler erhalten und deswegen ist
es System nicht auseinander geraten ganz
im Gegenteil wir sind gut rausgekommen
wir haben biontech
erlebt wo Wissenschaftler wo Forscher
uns die Möglichkeit gegeben haben
schnell einen Wirkstoff zu entwickeln
dass wir wirklich auch gesund aus der
Krise rauskommen und uns heute nicht
mehr fürchten Rheinland-Pfalz ja in
Rheinland-Pfalz aber auch in Marburg
aber aber also
Rheinland-Pfalz und Hessen also das wir
sind befreundet und
ganz ernsthaft aber auch in Marburg muss
man ja sagen und ich finde das ergänzt
sich da so und das ist natürlich gewesen
weil Bund und Länder Dinge austariert
haben und das haben wir dann jetzt auch
gemacht in dieser aus meiner Sicht noch
viel schwierigeren Situation ähm dieser
Energiekrise aus meiner Sicht ist das in
der Situation der wir uns derzeit
befinden eine der schwierigsten
Situationen nach dem Krieg meine
Generation kennt das gar nicht sie haben
ja auf meinem Geburtsdatum hingewiesen
ich erinnere mich noch an autofreie
Sonntage und so Geschichte
ich bin hier aufgewachsen um die Ecke an
der michelartikelsallee ich habe in der
wahlter vom radstraße gelebt das war
toll da konnten wir da Fahrrad fahren
und ja
weil durch die Brücken ist ja auch jetzt
wieder gestellt ja und wir konnten auf
die A66 fahren zu dem Brücken können wir
auch noch kommt ähm aber das machen wir
vielleicht später so jedenfalls ähm
jetzt haben wir etwas hinbekommen was
auch nicht selbstverständlich war und
was uns wahrscheinlich durch die Krise
durchführen wird es hat immer vielen
Geld zu tun dass wir nicht zugeben das
ist nicht ganz ungefährlich weil je mehr
Geld der Staat aufnimmt desto stärker
wird er natürlich auch der
Inflationstreiber da muss man sehr
aufpassen aber überlegen sich mal als es
am 24.02 los ging haben die Leute
gefragt wie wird das sein wird werde ich
im Kalten sitzen wie wird das sein werde
ich meine Rechnung bezahlen können wie
wird das sein werde ich meinen Betrieb
weiterführen können bislang haben wir
das ganz gut hinbekommen anfangs
würde der Bund unbedingt diese gasumlage
noch erinnern sich jugendberrettung und
so weiter das heißt hätte auf den
galoppierenden Gaspreis auf den
galoppieren Strompreis noch einen Preis
draufgesetzt das wäre irre geworden und
dann haben die insbesondere die Länder
und zwar über A und B Länder Grenzen
hinweg also über SPD und CDU führte
Länder hinweg Grenzen Weg gesagt das
wird so nicht funktionieren und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden das wird
das wird zu Problemen führen und dann
passiert das was Frau Werbung erzählt
hat es gibt Aufstände auf den
Marktplätzen und deswegen haben wir
gesagt wir müssen ein anderes Instrument
entwickeln und dann haben wir diese
ganzen strompreisbremse sie gucken schon
auf die Uhr ich sehe ist dann haben wir
auf die Gassen haben
ja dann haben wir die ganzen Strompreis
Bremse entwickelt die wirklich jetzt
richtig wirkt die auf die Wirtschaft
wirkt die auf jeden einzelnen von uns
wirkt also Bürgerinnen und Bürger als
Verbraucherin als Verbraucher und so
haben wir es doch hinbekommen bei allen
extremen Meinungsverschiedenheiten und
dass ich von dieser Bundesregierung
nichts halten liegt doch auf der Hand
aber trotzdem mal was hinbekommen weil
wir uns am Unternehmen gerissen haben
weil wir gesagt haben wenn wir es jetzt
nicht schaffen wir die Kräfte der Mitte
wenn wir das jetzt nicht hinbekommen
dann rutscht uns dieses Land weg und
dann wird es ein Konjunkturprogramm für
radikale werden die Linken und die
Rechten werden dieses Land übernehmen
wenn wir es nicht hinbekommen deswegen
müssen wir es jetzt hinbekommen und dann
haben wir das zusammengebaut was ich
eben genannt habe und das zeigt am Ende
kriegen wir es in Deutschland doch
verhältnismäßig gut miteinander hin also
wenn es uns schlecht genug geht also im
Land geht's eigentlich noch so gut ähm
ja das kommt das kommt ganz darauf an
wenn wir jetzt über die Verbote noch mal
reden und auch das erledigen dann wird
uns besser gehen
so lieber Matthias jetzt fliegt ihr mit
euren Verbrennungsmotoren da oben ins
Weltall und macht Fotos von dem blauen
Planeten und sagt oh aufpassen das ist
alles ganz fragil was haben wir
eigentlich von dieser Raumfahrt und dem
was ihr und auch letztlich du da oben
gemacht hast jetzt auf der Erde in der
Realität kostet ja alles auch ein
bisschen Geld ja kostet ein bisschen
Geld aber es denke ich mal sehr gut
investiert ist Geld weil wir den
gleichen benefit wir fliegen nicht nur
Verbrennungsmotoren gut eine normale
Rakete ist so wir haben mittlerweile
auch ionenantriebe also sehr innovative
Antriebe im All um Satelliten dann von A
nach B zu schieben im All nutzen wir
Solarzellen also die sind für alle
entwickelt worden war damals auch hat
man gefragt ja brauchen wir das
heutzutage wissen wir ohne Solarzellen
auf der Erde wäre wahrscheinlich auch
unsere
energieumstellung auf der Erde so nicht
möglich zu deiner regenerativen Energien
wir haben den Klimawandel ist eine große
Herausforderung aber woher wissen wir
denn dass wir den Klimawandel haben
hauptsächlich dank Satellitendaten 95
Prozent dieser Daten kommen aus dem All
das ist einmal Wetterdaten aber dann
noch langfristige Klimadaten die da
gemessen werden wir haben
Erdbeobachtungen aus dem alt sehen wir
nämlich gezielt wo auf der Erde gibt es
zum Beispiel Stellen wo Methan
freigesetzt wird das heißt wir können
dort genau zeigen dort ist eine Dutzend
Verursacher das müssen wir eingreifen
wir können aus dem All überwachen welche
Länder halten ihre Versprechen ein und
welche nicht wir können sehr viel aus
dem All dazu beitragen natürlich auch
die Kommunikation und die Satelliten
Navigation all das das Europäer Europa
führen gestern habe ich mir sagen lassen
von einer
studentenvertreterin ja also mit so
einem Wetter Satelliten damit erzählst
du keine Schlagzeilen auf tiktok da
musste schon zum Mond fliegen das kommt
geladen das heißt dieser macht natürlich
vieles und mehr
in einem Monat fliegen wir eine ganz
ganz tolle Mission zu den jupitermohnen
das heißt diese Mission heißt juice die
startet jetzt aber die kommt erst 20 33
34 dort an und dann wollen wir schauen
welche dieser Jupiter Monte Calisto
ghanimed und Europa hat also dort gibt
es gefrorenes Wasser und Ozeane welche
dieser gefrorenen Monde hat eventuell
das Potenzial für Leben unter dem Eis
also das ist normal so grundlegende
Fragen und da kann man sich natürlich
sagen brauchen wir das müssen wir das
haben einmal denke ich ja es ist
Inspiration aber zum anderen haben wir
dafür auch Technologie entwickelt die
wir dann viele Jahre später in unserem
Alltag wiederfinden werden wir könnten
uns unseren Alltag heute nicht mehr
vorstellen ohne die ganzen Technologie
die wir jetzt haben also jeder nutzte
Navigationssystem auf dem Handy Europa
hat er das beste Galileo in wenigen
Jahren werden wir auch mittels Handy
über Satelliten kommunizieren können
also das heißt das Internet wird überall
verfügbar sein die Kommunikation wird
immer besser sein und wir sehen jetzt
dass die Raumfahrt gerade diese
Revolution durchmacht die wir vor 20
Jahren beim Internet erlebt haben und
deswegen auch der große wegruf der ESA
an Europa lasst uns hier die Fälle nicht
wegschwimmen momentan sehen wir dass die
USA super aktiv sind dass der ganze
Markt der da entsteht und wir reden hier
über eine Billion an Wirtschaftsmarkt
bis 20 40 da muss Europa aktiv werden
also wir haben momentan die Möglichkeit
bleiben mal Zuschauer werden erkunde und
kaufen alles ein Pumpen unser Geld über
den Teich oder wollen wir Lieder werden
ja in den letzten Jahren sind wir ja mit
Russland ins All geflogen mit den USA
geflogen also immer so per Anhalter
durch die Galaxis und wir wollen jetzt
auch nachdem also Erdbeobachtungen
Navigation sind wir führen wir wollen
aber auch das Europa in autonomen Zugang
zum Alltag also es steht und auch
deshalb bist du hier past pro toto für
das was wir in Europa endlich mal wieder
hinbekommen müssen nämlich auch aus
eigener Kraft
Weltklasse zu sein und die anderen wenn
ich sag's einfach mal so auch zu uns auf
schauen zu lassen in der Tat geben wir
alles Mögliche aus der Hand in der
Plattform Ökonomie und so weiter in der
Medizin Apotheke der Welt gab es früher
mal und also die Beispiele gibt's zu
Hause in der Mobilkommunikation und und
und im Weltall ist das Rennen noch nicht
verloren und jetzt sagst du das ist hoch
attraktiv und in der Tat in Amerika ist
es ja auch eine privatwirtschaftliche
Geschichte inzwischen geworden
Milliardäre also multimilliardäre haben
eigene Raumfahrtunternehmen Jeff be von
Amazon du bist tatsächlich nicht mit
einer Ariane Rakete ins All geflogen
sondern mit einer space extra Rakete von
Elon Musk genau das heißt wir sind schon
total abhängig von dem ja wir haben also
15 Jahren war Europa führend im Bereich
Transport von kommerziellen Satelliten
und jetzt 15 Jahre später
haben wir in diesem Jahr drei Starts mit
europäischen Raketen SpaceX hat 100 also
damals in 15 Jahren ist das Blatt
komplett gekippt und jetzt haben wir
noch die Chance sozusagen in 10 Jahren
können das wieder korrigiert haben wenn
wir jetzt die die Weichen stellen also
da hat Raumfahrt auch etwas mit Politik
zu tun
man muss langfristig denken hat
natürlich auch den Nachteil ähm in vier
Jahren kann der Politiker der heute
entscheidet die Weichen zu stellen
leider noch nicht die Erfolge einfahren
das geht nicht das ist genau wie bei der
Bildung Investitionen in Schulen
Universitäten das sieht man auch in
einer Generation dann erst was das
gebracht hat und
deswegen dieser Weg doch weglaufen auch
wenn die Europäer noch mal hier
informieren dass er sagen im November
haben ein Space damit für ganz Europa
lasst uns hier investieren in die
Zukunft Europa kann das genauso gut wie
die USA
tja lieber Herr Ministerpräsident
Bildung es Ländersache da müssen sie
ganz viel Geld in Schulen investieren es
gibt eine hessische Raumfahrt Initiative
soll ich jetzt mal zum Glück wo auch da
der Blick drauf gerichtet wird in
Darmstadt ist dann ist ein großes ESA
Kontrollzentrum das einen Besuch wert
ist ich glaube da kann man auch wenn man
wirklich mal rein möchte gibt es
Möglichkeiten sich das mal anzuschauen
und all das so es kostet unglaublich
viel Geld jetzt haben sie aber ja gerade
gesagt sie dürfen es nicht so laut sagen
aber eigentlich ging es uns ja ganz gut
so dann ähm vielleicht ist jetzt die
Zeit inmitten einer industriellen
Revolution jetzt Gas zu geben und in all
diese Dinge zu investieren und
mal zu gucken was so sich mobilisieren
lässt und zwar ausdrücklich zusammen mit
der Privatwirtschaft siehe Elon Musk und
geht's denn dann jetzt los ist das schon
Teil des Wahlkampf nein das ist nicht
Teil des Wahlkampf sondern das ist Teil
in einer langen angelegten Strategie die
in der Tat und Politiker mögen natürlich
immer das einzusammeln was sie am Anfang
ihrer Legislatur quasi ausgestreut haben
das ist aber am Ende nicht
verantwortungsvolle Politik und wenn sie
sich mal hier umschauen und diesen
Campus sehen das ist eine
langzeitentwicklung gewesen ob jemals
Roland Koch dafür belohnt worden ist
dass er die Grundsatzentscheidung dafür
getroffen hat dass wir vom Campus
Bockenheim der völlig kaputt ist hierher
gekommen sind weiß ich nicht aber
jedenfalls das hat er einfach gemacht
weil es eine lange Linie gewesen ist
Hessen in der Wissenschaft und
Forschungspolitik zu verändern und dazu
gehört natürlich auch eine
raumfahrtstrategie eines Bundeslandes
ist lachen die Leute dann immer seinen
Raumfahrt Strategie eines Bundesland
sehr lächerlich denken daran wir würden
die Löwe eins auf dem Mond schicken oder
so das ist natürlich Quatsch es geht
nicht darum dass wir eine Rakete auf dem
Boden schicken wollen das können andere
besser sondern es geht darum dass wir
was macht der Land was schlau ist es
siedelt investiert in Wissenschaft und
Forschung ersiedelt an außer Universität
Forschungseinrichtungen es siedelt an
private Forschungseinrichtungen und ist
versucht sie zu vernetzen mit
Unternehmen die dann kommen weil die
klügsten Köpfe sind gekommen dann kommen
auch die Unternehmen die wiederum zahlen
Steuern und so ist es ein wunderbarer
Kreislauf und bringt ein Land wirklich
voran und deswegen haben wir diese
raumfahrtstrategie entwickelt und ich
glaube dass es sich lohnt wir haben in
Hessen das weiß kaum jemand ähm 100
Unternehmen die mittelbar und
unmittelbar mit Raumfahrt zu tun haben
und 50 Lehrstühle in Hessen alleine die
mit dem Thema zu tun haben da macht es
natürlich schon Sinn dass alles
zusammenzufügen eine Strategie zu
entwickeln und das bringt uns wieder was
wir können beispielsweise wenn jemand
wie Herr Maurer kommt oder Herr Gerst
oder wer auch immer von ihnen das
fasziniert junge Leute Nachmittag ist
noch eine Astronautin also
das ist fasziniert eben junge Leute für
all die Themen Mint alles Wasser an
Naturwissenschaften eine Rolle spielt
das begeistert für das Thema das
begeistert eben auch offen malen für
Forschung und dann eben so zu sprechen
wie er zu sagen Leute das Pferd ist
nicht gegen die Mauer sondern man kann
weitermachen ich glaube dass das sehr
hilfreich ist und am Ende ist die ist
die ist ist die Grundlage von allem sie
haben es gesagt die Investitionen
Bildung auch das war hier nicht immer
Tradition in diesem Land in wir
investieren in diesem Haushalt alleine 5
Milliarden Euro in den ganzen
Bildungsbereich ich glaube das ist am
Ende Lohn und das ist am Ende auszahlt
und ob man dafür irgendwann mal ein Lohn
einsammelt oder nicht wenn ein Politiker
klar denken Politiker grundsätzlich so
aber wenn sie anfangen so zu denken wenn
sie niemals etwas voranbringen und
niemals eine lange Linie legen und auch
wenn sie es vielleicht nicht für möglich
halten auch Politiker können
verantwortungsvoll sein und
verantwortungsvolle lange Linie legen
weil sie doch irgendwie ja Politiker
geworden sind nicht weil sie alle fünf
Jahre wieder gewählt werden wollen
sondern weil sie irgendetwas bewegen
wollen und irgendetwas für ihr Land
bewirken wollen und die Idee haben
das ist gut zu hören und trotzdem hat
die Frau Professor Grimm gerade zurecht
sagen können es geht alles viel zu
langsam ich also sie wollen was bewegen
und das Planungsrecht ist eine
Katastrophe und wir haben angeblich in
Deutschland Tempo gut in Berlin weiß man
nicht aber also
davon merkt man an wenigen Stellen
ehrlich gesagt im Moment etwas ja also
im All geht schneller voran wir reden
gleich noch mal darüber wann wir auf dem
Mond wieder sind ja ich will sie jetzt
nicht mit äh landespolitischen kleinen
langweilen wirklich nicht aber es gibt
natürlich also das sind natürlich auch
narrative die nicht mehr so insgesamt
Stimmen klar könnte vieles viel
schneller voran gehen aber gucken ich
habe eben über Bayern Tag wir haben über
Rheinland-Pfalz über Marburg gesprochen
das ging schnell wir haben über die
Terminals für das Flüssigkeit gesprochen
das ging sehr schnell als geht in der
ein oder anderen Stelle dann doch sehr
schnell und wir haben doch in der
letzten Legislaturperiode in Bund auf
der Bundesebene beispielsweise keine
Planfeststellungsverfahren mehr zu
machen für einen Brückensanierungen auf
Bundesstraßen das haben wir übersetzt
auf Hessen wir machen das bei Kreisen
Landesstraßen auch nicht mehr das geht
also schon viel schneller sondern würden
sie jetzt wenn ich jetzt sie wäre Knoten
würde ich sagen aber gucken Sie mal bei
Ihnen an wie das mit den Windrädern
läuft das geht viel zu langsam in Hessen
vollkommen richtig das geht viel zu
langsam hat aber damit zu tun dass wir
uns natürlich auch oftmals selbst
Fesseln anlegen wir sind ein Rechtsstaat
und das heißt wir sind ein Instanzen
Start und das ist gut so jeder kann
klagen wenn ihm etwas nicht passt das
ist einfach Ausdruck einer Demokratie
das will ich nicht verändern was ich
aber verändern willst die Beschleunigung
von Verfahren das ist der Grund warum
wir in Hessen gesagt haben unsere
Gerichte müssen besser ausgestattet
werden das läuft zu langsam die
Geschichte von ich krieg R1 und geh um
eins die stimmt ja schon lange nicht
mehr sondern Richter sind voll mit
Verfahren und deswegen müssen wir mehr
stellen die Justiz schaffen quer durch
die ganze Justiz haben wir gemacht jetzt
500 neue Stellen für die hessische
Justiz ist ein neuer Justiz neuer
Justizminister ist die ist die größte
die größte stellenvolumen was mir jemals
auf einen Schlag in Hessen geschaffen
haben und das führt dazu dass wir in
Kassel beim Verwaltungsgerichtshof einen
extra Senat einrichten jetzt für genau
diese Großprojekte Windräder Autobahnen
Beschleunigung etc das ist der
Flaschenhals gewesen den weiten wir
jetzt und wie gesagt es hört sich nach
landespolitischen kleinen an aber das
sind halt so die Einzelbausteine mit
denen man dann Dinge beschleunigen kann
und so hat jeder auf seiner staatlichen
eben halt auch seine Verantwortung auf
Bundesebene haben Verfahren versucht mit
der Bundesregierung zu verhandeln einen
planigung ein Planungs- und
beschleunigungsmaßnahmen Paket ist
irgendwo zwischen Autobahn
Beschleunigung und Windrad
Beschleunigung zwischen FDP und Grünen
hängen geblieben dann haben wir das im
Dezember mit den weiter besprechen
wollen hat der Bundeskanzler das von der
Tagesordnung genommen dann haben die uns
gesagt sie machen diesen
Koalitionsausschuss das hätte er am
ersten dritten sein sollen und es ist
ihm Nirvana verschwunden jetzt müssen
wir wieder sagen es muss wieder auf den
Tisch wir müssen da ankommen also es ist
manchmal mühsam aber mühsam nährt sich
das Eichhörnchen und wir kriegen auch
das hin und wir werden auch Darsteller
werden weil wir haben ja kein
erkenntnisprobleme wir wissen ja wo die
Probleme sind wir müssen jetzt wirklich
stückweise lösen und da finde ich sind
wir auf einem besseren Weg als man
manchmal die Geschichte erzählt
okay
die Finger scross jetzt gibt es eine
hessische raumfahrtstrategie dazu noch
kurz auch ein Wort von dir ist es
sinnvoll dass also the warrior was weiß
ich gibt's ja sowieso schon länger ja
und und also Hessen hat auch andere
Bundesländer vielleicht auch aber ihr
seid doch die ESA brauchen wir nicht
eine also eine europäischen eine
europäischen Ansatz auch in dem Ductus
den du eben gerade sagtest mit also
Europapark first so
das wäre die erste Frage fangen wir
erstmal kurz damit an und fliegen dann
auf den Mond genau
raumfahrtstrategie gibt die gibt's in
Deutschland auch eine nationale
raumfahrtstrategie die ist allerdings
von 2009 und die ist schon lange
überfällig weil 2009 ähm da gab es noch
nicht diese Privatwirtschaft die den
ganzen Zugang zum allerersten hatte und
ähm die nationale raumfahrtstrategie die
wird jetzt gerade überarbeitet und
angepasst
und da möchten wir dass die dann auch
mutig ist dass die Spielräume erlaubt
weil in den nächsten Jahren wird sich
sehr sehr viel wandeln der erdner Orbit
der wird an die Industrie übergeben
werden also ich war auf der
Internationalen Raumstation das sind
Gemeinschaftsprojekt zwischen NASA Isa
und anderen Partnern aber halt immer
Raumfahrtagenturen und in ein paar
Jahren 2030 wird das Ende der
internationalen Raumstation sein und wir
möchten natürlich weiterhin dorthin
fliegen weil wir dort tolle Dinge machen
können nämlich Forschung und
Schwerelosigkeit kann man Dinge lernen
die wir auf der Erde so nicht
untersuchen können es
Grundlagenforschung auch oft und was ja
eben schon gesehen nur werden
Grundlagenforschung investiert der kann
wenn es dann auch die Not gebietet dann
schnell irgendwelche Ergebnisse und
wissen halt vorziehen und daraus
Anwendung bauen
so und 20 30 jetzt das Ende der
internationalen Raumstation was machen
wir dort in Amerika sind schon vier
Konsortium die privatstationen bauen
wollen
das heißt dort kann man dann in Zukunft
bei einer Firma sich in Weltraum
Aufenthalt buchen als ich im All war kam
schon zwei Raumkapseln vorbei mit
Touristen das ist jetzt Alltag in der
einen Kapsel war ein Japaner dabei der
hatte sogar seinen persönlichen
Assistentin dabei also mitgebracht ja
das ist jetzt so das ganze
bearbeitet oder das merkt man jetzt gut
finden oder nicht ist aber leider Fakt
daran kann man nicht mehr vorbei ich
denke das ganze muss man ähm der
tiefgestalten so dass es Sinn ergibt
dadurch dass mehr Menschen ins All
fliegen dann haben wir natürlich auch
mehr Botschafter die von der Schönheit
der Erde berichten können aber auch sage
ich mal Botschafter für die Erde sind
Klima zu schützen das Klima zu bewahren
das ist etwas das glaube ich jeder
Astronaut sofort mitnimmt aber diese
privatastronauten die oben waren hatten
auch immer Forschung mit dabei wir sind
auch Sponsoren für Forschung das heißt
die hatten wir dann viel schneller
Zugang von gewissen Experimenten die
über die klassischen altenwege dann
vielleicht zehn Jahre gebraucht hätten
bis sie oben sind weil einfach sehr viel
geprüft und getestet wird also du bist
da offen wenn man da bin ich bin nicht
offen dadurch ist mehr Leute ins All
fliegen wird es auch günstiger für alle
auch günstige für die Wissenschaft
günstig auf einen Steuerzahlern aber
klar aber wir müssen natürlich aufpassen
wenn viele Leute hochlegen dann ist das
natürlich auch dann erzeugen wir Müll im
All ja aber da sorgt die ESA ja komplett
demnächst alles auch
klappen würde da haben wir noch keinen
Konzept wir müssen aufpassen dass es
allen nicht so zugemüllt wird wie die
Welt mehrere weil in der Vergangenheit
was so die Welt mehr da jeder hat gesagt
dass diesen unendlich groß wenn ich da
ein bisschen Müll rein kippe das stört
hier nicht jetzt wissen wir mittlerweile
finden den Müll in der Nahrungskette
wieder
und der Mensch ist irgendwie so erwacht
erst auf wenn es weh tut irgendwann wird
es auch im All weh tun wenn wir nämlich
zu viel Müll haben dann
kollidieren Satelliten mit einem anderen
Satelliten und dann wird dort eine
Staubwolke entstehen und dass wir dann
so eine Kettenreaktion winziges Teilchen
reicht schon um als ich oben war ich war
vier Tage im allen hatte Russland
ein Satelliten abgeschossen das war
meiner Meinung nach schon so eine Art
Vorstufe vom Ukraine kriegen um zu
zeigen hier wir können euch oben auch
eure Infrastruktur kaputt machen und das
hatten eine riesen ähm Folge
zur Folge gehabt und das ist eine Gefahr
die Augen haben die Infrastruktur die
wir haben alle haben die ist so wichtig
für unser Alltagsleben wir möchten uns
gar nicht vorstellen was passiert wenn
wir keine Satelliten mehr nutzen können
das heißt dort auch dann achtsam sein
jetzt noch ganz ganz kurz weil der
bringt alles rot und überhaupt ähm genau
warum zum Mond ganz kurz ja der Mond
liegt vor der Haustür jeder versteht wo
der Mond ist ist zum Greifen nah und auf
dem Mond können wir super viel lernen
für die Erde wir können dort sehen
lernen wie es auf Sonnensystem
entstanden und das hilft uns bei der
Beantwortung der Frage gibt es dort
draußen noch mal eine zweite Erde
und das ist spannend hat sich
vorzustellen wie wäre das Leben dort
draußen wie ist es entstanden also wir
lernen sehr viel über uns selbst und
alles was wir lernen können wir
hoffentlich dann auch anwenden unseren
Planeten zu schützen immer zu maßdenken
der Maß hatte mal ähm was an der
Oberfläche ist jetzt ein Wüstenplanet
geworden also Klimawandel im extremsten
den Maß den wollen wir nicht imitieren
das heißt immer verstanden haben wieder
Maß entgleist ist dann können wir
hoffentlich auch diese Fehler in der
Erde vermeiden
Herr Ministerpräsident die letzte Frage
an Sie auch wieder ein anderer Besucher
in der Redaktion hatte vor einiger Zeit
den verwegenen Vorschlag die sollten
alle gar nicht mehr großartig darüber
reden was sie alles Vorhaben sondern
einfach machen das ist in der Demokratie
jetzt nicht so leicht ich wollte gerade
Antworten also das ist glaube ich
exaktes falsche Rezept wir müssen schon
darüber reden und wir müssen mit
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern darüber reden
wir müssen zu Abstimmung stellen wir
müssen Transparenz herstellen wir müssen
Partizipation herstellen also wenn wir
das nicht mehr machen würden dann werden
wir nicht mehr in der Demokratie sondern
dann hätte das schon ich sag mal sehr
autokratische Züge ist kein Land in dem
ich leben möchte aber wir wollen in
einem Land leben wo sie als Eltern und
Großeltern mit ihren Kindern und Enkeln
darüber reden was sie groß ist erreichen
können und wohin sie gucken sollen damit
sie inspiriert werden
damit sie das richtige wählen damit Sie
aber auch sozusagen für sich die
richtige Berufswahl treffen dass sie
vielleicht sich mal wieder von
Fischertechnik oder Lego minds
inspirieren lassen und nicht nur von
tiktok und ich denke auch dafür war das
ein toller Impuls lieber Matthias lieber
Ministerpräsident danke dass Sie und ihr
beide da war danke fürs aufmerksame
zuhören
vielen Dank
so genau und jetzt stehen sie auch in
diesem Fall völlig zu Recht auf zu mir
wirklich noch mal leid dass die letzte
Pause
ausgefallen ist ich glaube aber völlig
zu Recht wenn ich mir jetzt diese sehr
inspirierende in der tatrunde angeschaut
habe jetzt aber wirklich Pause es gibt
auch was zu essen lassen Sie es gut
schmecken und wir sehen uns hier wieder
um Viertel nach eins 13:15 Uhr mit dem
Herausgeber Taube und im Gespräch mit
Tatort Kommissarin Margarita Bruch eine
gute Zeit bis dahin
[Applaus]